[Music]  no mage the Vallot new nanny even 1927  clear modern folk  [Music]  blowing me  the king and queen are coming to town -  what  [Applause]  [Music]  I want every surface to gleam and  sparkle  a royal luncheon a parade under dinner  I'm going to have to sit down how's it  all going Barry's got it under control  hardly  I need your help Carson I'll be there in  the morning milady don't you worry  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so we really go on with it you mean  leave Danton  Downton Abbey's the hearts of this  community and you're keeping it beating  [Music]  remember to pray for us I'll put in a  word  [Applause]  your Majesties welcome to Downton Abbey  will you have enough cliches to get you  through the visit if not I'll come to  you here we go  [Music]  you  you